i think the cryptocurrency thing is an
interesting
approach to
reducing the um
error in the
the database that is called money
um
you know i think i have a pretty deep
understanding of the of what money
actually is on a practical day-to-day
basis because of paypal um
you know i really
got in deep there um
and
right right now the money system
actually for
practical purposes is
is is really a bunch of heterogeneous uh
mainframes running uh old cobalt
okay you mean literally that's literally
that's literally what's happening in
batch mode
okay in patch mode yeah
pretty the poor fastest who have to
maintain that code okay that's a
that's a pain less pain not even for
trans cobalt yep that's cobol
like and they still
banks are still buying mainframes in
2021 and running ancient cobalt code
uh and uh
you know the the federal reserve is like
probably even older than the what the
banks have and they have an old cobalt
mainframe
and so now
and so the the government effectively
has editing privileges on the on the
money database
and they use those editing privileges to
make more money
whenever they want
and this increases the error in the
database that is money so i think money
should really be viewed through the lens
of information theory
and uh and so it's uh
you're kind of like uh like an internet
connection like what's the bandwidth uh
you know
total bit rate uh what is the latency
judder
uh packet drop uh you know
errors in errors in the network uh
communication
using money like that basically
um i think that's probably right what
you think of it
and and then say what what system
uh
from an information theory standpoint
allows an economy to function the best
uh
and
you know um
crypto is an attempt to reduce the
the error
uh in
uh in money that is contributed by
uh governments uh
diluting the money supply
as basically a pernicious pernicious
form of taxation
so both policy in terms of with
inflation and actual like technological
cobalt like cryptocurrency takes us into
the 21st century in terms of the actual
systems that allow you to do the
transaction to store wealth all those
kinds of things
like i said just think of money as
information people
often will think of money as having
power in and of itself
it does not money is uh is information
and it does not have power in and of
itself
uh
the like the you know again applying the
the physics
tools of thinking about things in the
limit
is helpful if you are stranded on a
tropical island
and
you have a trillion dollars it's useless
because there's no there's no resource
allocation
money is a database resource allocation
but there's no resources to allocate
except yourself
so money is useless
uh
if you're stranded on desert island with
no food you'd uh all the bitcoin in the
world
will
not stop you from starving yeah
so
um
so like just think of money as as a
database for resource allocation um
across time and space
and
um and then what what what system
uh it is what what
in what form should that that
database or data system
what what would be most effective now
the there's a there is a fundamental
issue with um say bitcoin in its current
form
uh in that it's the transaction volume
is very limited um
and uh the
latency this if the latency for for a
properly confirmed transaction is to is
too long much longer than you'd like
so it's not it's actually not great from
a transaction volume standpoint or a
latency standpoint
so it is perhaps useful as
to search to solve an aspect of the
money database problem
uh
which is a sort of store of wealth or an
accounting of
relative obligations i suppose
but it is not useful as a
currency as a day-to-day currency but
people have proposed different
technological solutions
yeah lightning network and the layer two
technologies on top of that i mean it's
it's all it seems to be all kind of a
trade-off but the point is it's kind of
brilliant to say that just think about
information think about what kind of
database what kind of infrastructure
enables yeah like you're operating an
economy
um
and you need to have some
thing that
allows for the efficient
to have efficient uh value ratios
between products and services so you've
got this massive number of products and
services and you need to
you can't just barter it's just like
that would be extremely unwieldy uh so
you need something that gives you
the the uh
ratio of exchange between goods and
services
um
and and then something that allows you
to
shift obligations across time like debt
debt and equity shift obligations across
time
you